これからか雑魚ですはい今回の動画ですね皆様御を我慢したことありません
人というものは水分というものを取り入れて体を循環させて料として排出して
な動きはもう作っておりますつまりすべている人間は水分を摂りいれて量を排出する店
がこの中でもし尿というものを我慢するとどんなような世界が見えてくるか我慢した先
に何が見えるのか
恐怖と見て行きたいと思いますで今からちょっとつい
を取り入れた上で日本の結果には超えていこうと思うんですけどもやっぱりは揺れ2人
だと不安なので今回は
量の
スペシャにするお越しいただきますどうぞ
ふざけるのが入ってよ僕にものスペシャリストじゃないですよ
全然一さん
匠さん
はいというわけで今回このサーフィンでちょっとだけを食べた限界に迫ってみようと
思いますじゃあ実績があるんですよ
説明なんかにも我慢したんだよって誰定も作って両我慢することによるとちょっと
不思議な作用があるという情報を入れました俺の後輩からの情報なんですけどもう一青
が問題隙間によるとこしこしたくなってから6時間かも
すってきれいに尿放出するとピリオドの向こうが
という天国にいる感覚を味わえるません幽体離脱見て違います6時間我慢に失敗してや
療法室にも失敗するとホースの覚醒というアホみたいに金
量がペラの中にお米になるっていう地獄絵図が見れるらしいぞぉ方が入っております
格好が後輩だったら結構感じですね本文で医学的根拠に基づく情報なのでこの状況で
1人2本ずつ hd くる分身体に水分を蓄えます
マフやすいかも知れてさんにでも同じ西武ルールって誰が先に6時間尿を我慢して
ピリオドの向こう後にたどり着けるかたまた6時間がはに失敗して放送の覚醒に陥る
なさそう
まずは成分を体に入れていきましょうおい入っ
ございません
これ
逆によってくる
ん
うーんダブルスとマジで落ちちゃうってくるよ null
結婚においだよなぁ
の怖いのは膀胱炎とかなんで
勧めしすぎると本当に体が害が出るんでず分の中なきゃいけばいいね
夏場家で負けたらこれのもならん
7分
じゃあ結構よい
俺全然記者よ
ああぁっっ goo
音が入った
[音楽]
見れば映画にそれはないよってれ ba
まあ見てちょっとこと聞いて見せまして
パパ嫌だっけ
うふふふーぷよっ
ううっすればこので増えていかないと
おっ
[音楽]
ブーブー
主でもある意味酵素がカクッということで
にょーっ
下から出れから浴衣でるっベテランで気づくともう一時間経っておりました
思うなんだアンクシャなんかは分からんしゅん動いたらダメでしょしやばい方
[音楽]
福はーちゃんと
便器にしていきますこんなバカなことやりましょう開いて外で二人だった沢山ですけど
も掃除機僕はもう限界ですたそうと振動でももうすぐでそうなレベルなんだようまく
タメだでるでるぜぶりだ
1てー
がんばれ
5がいきましょうもうお前やっぱ5万円頑張ってやばいやばい持っているくまってはい
いやもうこれはもう
成長しですようん
意志の問題ですよこれは私がプレ真面目を爪をはじめ
真面目はじめっはじめ
ああああああああ
わー
あっはぁっすごいじゃんねぇちょっとねぇ
ちょいとラグーナ尽きるわけじゃない
赤ちゃん値が違うんじゃないあっホイチョインっにじゃあ
ni
をています